all right good afternoon i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department i'm out here this afternoon
to brief you on a
murder-suicide investigation that we are
conducting at calico basin
which is off of state route 159 also
known as charleston boulevard
the details that i have right now are
very preliminary but at around 1 15 this
after
at around 1 15 this afternoon
officers
rangers with the
bureau of land management were on
routine patrol directly behind me
one of the rangers noticed a vehicle
that was parked illegally off the side
of the road
when he exited his car he walked up and
he found the body of a woman in her
mid-30s suffering from what appears to
be a self-inflicted gunshot wound
in the car seat directly next to the
mother was the body of a
child under the age of two suffering
from a gunshot wound
at this point we believe the child is
the
son of the deceased
suspect
right now again still early on in the
investigation urge anybody who has any
information to reach out to crime
stoppers that information can be
anonymous but again there's still a lot
of things that we're looking into at
this point
i will tell anyone
who is in a situation where you're under
tremendous stress there are many
resources out in the community you can
call 2-1-1 you can drop your child off
at a hospital you can call child
protective services again there are a
lot of resources out there
to prevent such a tragic situation that
we're out here investigating right now
so with that i'll take a couple
questions if you have them right what
makes it apparent that at least
initially the gunshot wound is
self-inflicted
again she does have a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the head just from
examining the crime scene and the there
is a weapon inside the car just from our
examination it's obvious that it is
self-inflicted
from evidence that's inside the
at least self-inflicted to her the
injuries
she committed the injuries to the child
how old is the child i'm not giving out
the exact age i'll say he is under the
age of two it did appear being here
early that visitors were being escorted
out of the park as it was shut down tell
me a little about what made that
necessary or were they evacuated if you
would well right now
because the crime scene was taped off
initially the people who were here
hiking they had taped it off early so
they couldn't get past the actual crime
scene the scene is actually directly
next to the road so we've done we've
we're able to shield the car at least
the best we can and get the people that
were in the area hiking out of here so
they're not being stuck out here all
afternoon
because the area is still open
what's that the area
it is still the area still closed off
we're allowing residents to enter and
then the people that were up here hiking
are able to leave but until
we're done processing the calico basin
will be closed
it was a ranger who was driving down the
highway and he noticed the car parked
off the side of the road and it was
parked in an area that there's no
parking and that ranger walked up to the
vehicle and that's how he discovered the
scene
still too early to get into that we
haven't processed the scene it's going
to be a couple hours and we're still
waiting on the corner and we'll have
that information any details on the
woman ethnicity
i'm not going to get too specific i'll
say she's in her mid-30s but as far as
i'll leave it at that for now and was it
a handgun
it is a handgun right thank you guys i
appreciate it